guys I knew it back in 1994 when I saw
angels in the outfield that kid was
going someplace Don John is directed by
Joseph gordon-levitt written by him and
starring him as well this is his
directorial debut it also stars Tony
Danza Scarlett Johansson and Julianne
Moore this movie is basically about the
ultimate man he's a bartender you don't
really see him at work too much you just
know what he does but he loves girls
he's constantly at the bars he's always
sleeping with random women and he's also
kind of addicted to pornography and when
he finally meets a girl that he might
actually connect with in Scarlett
Johansson this pornography thing becomes
kind of a difficulty with him as he's
trying to figure out how to have a
natural relationship while in the midst
of this fantasy world that he sort of
had himself encased in for a really long
time but it's not just that one simple
plot that he's trying to get used to a
normal relationship having been used to
a sort of fantasy view of it in the past
there's a lot more happening in this
movie there's a great commentary on the
way men and women view love and how both
of them have a sort of fantastical view
of it just through different mediums and
different forms of entertainment and
this movie has a lot to say about that
but also has a lot to say about
relationships and human nature in
general and this is definitely one of my
favorite films of the entire year I
cannot believe how great this movie is
this movie not only looks great and is
directed with a lot of flair and
confidence but the script is so
interesting and hilarious and really
real I don't think I've ever agreed more
with the characters opening monologue
for a film I mean everything out of this
guy's mouth I was like yep that's true
yep uh-huh that's how I feel yeah that's
that's how it is
see you could call this movie a romantic
comedy and it could be billed as that
but it's really it's not it has certain
elements that 50/50 had where it had
some really serious tones in there and
some really heartwarming things and some
really effective elements as well some
very seriously powerful stuff but it's
also very light-hearted and funny at the
same time and it's so fast-paced because
the style of directing that Joseph
gordon-levitt shows for this movie which
is edited so well with terrific use of
sound and imagery to really boost the
feeling that you get from this movie
because yes it's a movie about a guy
who's addicted to porn he's trying to
heaven
relationship but it's it's nothing
really about that that is just the
central plot that's what the back of the
blu-ray will say this movie has so much
to say about the way people act when
they're in a relationship or about the
way that men tend to get really all
excited about pornography one it is just
sort of a fantasy of sorts where it's
not real but else shows the way that
women can get really into these huge
fantastical movie romances that are so
unrealistic and will never happen it's
the exact same thing for two different
genders it's just that their different
forms of entertainment and one is more
graphic so to speak but it's really the
same thing and this movie explores that
beautifully and I love that about this
movie it was so clever and it's the kind
of movie that a guy can go to and think
man I'm kind of a dick it's the kind of
movie that a girl can go to and think
man I'm kind of a bitch it just reveals
all these truths about men and women and
how we interact with each other that
just it really floored me honestly like
I was so impressed with the script of
this film it was so well written also
some terrific supporting roles in this
movie for one Tony Danza as Joseph
gordon-levitt's dad in this movie is
awesome he is so good as this dad we
know he loves football he loves the
basics she's a real man's man but he is
just he's so good in this movie like I
do I didn't look at him and see Tony
Danza you know I was afraid when I saw
him on the cast as I was like really
Tony Danza that's interesting because
they also work together on angels in the
outfield it's kind of funny to see them
in this movie again almost 20 years
later I find that very very cool
actually but he was so good in the movie
and another really good supporting role
was Julianne Moore she played a student
at the school that Joe scorned lever was
going to she was great in the movie she
really added a lot to the film a really
important role really and I thought she
did a great job in the movie this movie
defies genre conventions it boys cliches
at all cost
in fact it is an all-out assault on
romantic cliches very much so like 500
days of summer was and I really really
liked what Joseph gordon-levitt is doing
with his career he is definitely one of
the best talents working in the industry
today I love Don John I thought it was a
very sweet movie extremely funny but
also very real and heartwarming in a
good way not in a cheesy way but you
watched the movie and you really feel
like yes I can completely relate to
these characters in these situations
because I've experienced this before or
I know someone who has
and that's what the best types of
stories are in movies where you feel as
if you can relate to these people you
forget you're watching a movie and
that's all I asked for in the movie can
you maybe give me 90 minutes or two
hours or whatever where I actually feel
invested to the point where I care about
the people on the screen and donjon for
sure does that it has a lot to say about
relationships about romance and it's
just a really entertaining movie at the
same time I'm gonna give Don John and a
plus I don't have any problems with this
movie it's fantastic I can't wait to
pick it up on blu-ray it is definitely
one of my favorite films of the year
when Don John comes out in late
September definitely go check it out
guys it is pretty awesome so thanks very
much for watching guys what's your
favorite Joseph gordon-levitt movie I'm
interested in knowing and what are your
thoughts on Don John when you eventually
do see it I know it has screen to a lot
of festivals so if you have seen it
what'd you think of it did you enjoy the
film
as always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my nice
Oh